so is it legal is it even possible to
annul a presidency Julien Epstein is a
Democrat and former counsel to the House
Judiciary Committee he joins us now so
join I I have notice that the left has
become more than anything a religious
movement and the use of the term
annulment kind of proves it
if the presidency were annulled as rice
suggests would heretics who persist on
acknowledging that Trump was once
president when they'd be punished it's a
funny way to put the question I don't
think annulment is a serious argument I
don't think we're at the threshold of
impeachment yet I think there is a
tendency going on with Democrats right
now as there was during the 98 Clinton
impeachment for people in the opposition
party to scream loud yes and to try to
get an attention and to scream kind of
louder than the other because it helps
with clicks on websites and it helps get
them on television but I don't think
it's a serious argument it's I think
when I had many debates during in PBA so
long we've known each other and there
were people who were claiming that Bill
Clinton murdered someone at Mena air
sites you know there was a lot of that
stuff wasn't Vince Foster for sure but
it wasn't called from former cabinet
secretaries Burton Dan Burton Congress
who had all kinds of theories but he was
embarrassed to those theories and when
confronted with music oh I didn't really
think that here you have pillars of the
Democratic establishment saying on
television things that are so far out in
extreme I'm not even sure how to respond
to them does that make you uncomfortable
I don't know if he's a pillar of the
Democratic establishment I think he was
a labor secretary under Clinton and I
think he's a very good economist I think
he's a sharp thinker as an economist he
is not a lawyer and I don't think he's a
legal scholar and I think he'd probably
do better staying away from that I think
there were plenty of Republican members
of Congress that's a very extremist
things during Clinton impeachment so I
think it happens on both sides it's a
natural thing that occurs anybody in
there you know Clinton of treason so
here you have a little Clinton of murder
but not in public I mean they sort of
whispered about it but you didn't have
for example a former head of the CIA
does it bother you
actually that John Brennan who was
compounded by Republicans by the way
when he first got in one concede that
but he was the head of the CIA and now
he's accusing a political opponent of a
death-penalty offense with no evidence
does it bother you that he ran the most
powerful intelligence agency in the
world well I think what Brennan was
referring to and people use treason in
different ways people sometimes use
treason in a legal sense and sometimes
people use treason in a more vernacular
sense and I think what what Brennan was
talking about was was was Trump
continually cozying with Putin who I
think most Republicans would agree is an
enemy of the United States is component
of the United States I would agree with
that I mean certainly no more
bloodthirsty than lots of middle east I
think if you look at what he's done with
the airliners I think if you were raised
in Crimea and Syria I don't think he's a
guy that's looking out for us in of
course he's not looking out for US
interests and so what a lot of that was
the point but look I think you can go
back and forth we could go back to as we
did in 98 and you go baby there you can
find extremists on both sides who will
say things that again I think are
designed to get attention
well television get clickbait for sure
but then you also and what you're saying
is absolutely right but you also have
people like I don't know the ranking
Democrat on the House Intelligence ear
questions about the evidence of
collusion so you do have a kind of
different level of extremism I would
argue but it leads to this question
which is if Trump is guilty of these
crimes that virtually ever on the left
alleges then why aren't we just saying
that there's an impeachment coming why
are Democrats ashamed of that as to the
question of extremism there's a lot of
extremism going on on both sides and I
hope as a thoughtful guy that you are
that you would denounce it the extremism
that's occurring on the right i denounce
the extremism that's occurring on the
left
I think the Robert Reich article was
ridiculous that's the quest quite point
the second point is not everybody in the
left is saying Trump is guilty of crimes
I don't think there's proof yet that
Trump is guilty of crimes I think the
question on campaign finance as we were
discussing before we came on air I don't
think that reaches an impeachable
offense and I think it's questionable is
whether it reaches illegal offense
because of the ambiguity of campaign
finance laws we can talk about that me
well of course I a great thing the
question on collusion rests entirely on
whether Trump had a
Vance knowledge of any illegal activity
that was connected to Russian hacking
that has not been proven yet
so this Democrat is not alleging a crime
as involved as it involved Donald Trump
but you know is that the the pressure
and the polls bear this out the pressure
from Democratic voters to impeach if
Democrats retake the house will be so
overwhelming that what speaker could
look at the people who just put him or
her in that position say you know we're
not impeaching well say what I was gonna
say one of the reasons that I think
there's so much pressure around these
investigations is how badly the Trump
White House has handled the Russian
investigation matter it looks at every
turn that they are trying to cover up
crimes whether it is the firing the the
threatened firings the promises of
pardons the all of the flipping of the
witness so that the accountant has
flipped on the president his attorney is
flipped on the president campaign
manager the poor way and you don't see
the same as being guilty no it's not oh
no no no Tucker not in a legal world but
in a political way you know as well as I
do that the actions of this White House
have looked guilty from the beginning
has made them look guilty it doesn't
mean that they're guilty in a legal
sense but it has been handled horribly
now the Democrats where the Democrats
ought to be and what I would argue and
I've spoken to Democrats on the hill is
they they should not be coming to legal
conclusions or in conclusions about
impeachment of this but can they resist
they should be can they their voters are
smart well this is this is the problem
with the polarized politics as we play
to the extreme bases and Republicans do
this I think I would argue more so than
Democrats do but we can different
disagree about it let's see that all you
can disagree about that but if Democrats
were smart they would tell the base that
we're not going to kind of kowtow to the
impulses that may make you feel better
emotionally we're gonna do what you and
I would probably agree if you can find
one Democratic leader with the huevos to
say something like that on television
I'll give you 20 bucks well I think
that's basically what the Democrats are
saying in other words and what the
Democrats ought to be saying Tucker yeah
is we're almost at we're not gonna make
conclusions about impeachment we're not
going to make conclusions of our
prosecution we want
to come out we want to protect the
independent council and all the other
investigations that are underway we
shouldn't protect the integrity in the
investigation tell the trees flowers
just allow the facts to come out and you
ought to be there and I to be there and
we had to say let's make it a safe since
day one I just see really it's been
charged are you for the Republican plan
the Senate bipartisan Republican plan
that protects the for running the
government in like rescuing the middle
class from oblivion what about the
Grassley bill that would protect
especially kind of special kind I don't
know I don't think we should have any
special counsels of any kind it's
unaccountable to the voters now that we
have specifications do you think that I
just wanted to go away and think about
what I'm serious and think about why
seventy thousand people died of drug
Gordy's Lester there's like real stuff
going on you just said that you think
there are the integrity of the
investigation ought to be proactive I
think it's just the whole thing is so
stupid I've run out of patience for it
but that's not why I asked you to come
on tonight Julian thank you very much
thanks for having me Tucker